This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 2016, the Swedish Tourist Association announced a new service called the Swedish number. If you dial the telephone number plus 4-6-771-793-336, you will be connected with a random suite. You will soon be connected to a random suite somewhere in Sweden. Hello. Hello, big Ula. Hello. Hello and welcome to Sweden. Oh hi, is this a random Swedish person?
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2016年，瑞典旅游协会宣布了一项名为“瑞典号码”的新服务。如果你拨打+46-771-793-336这个电话，你就会被随机连接到一位瑞典人。你很快就会被连接到瑞典某处的随机一位瑞典人。喂。喂，大乌拉。喂。喂，欢迎来到瑞典。哦，你好，这是随机的一位瑞典人吗？
Yeah, this is Swedish person. Okay. Cold calling the suite is Will Kohli. I'm a reporter and I have one question for you. What do you think of when I tell you the date 3rd of September 1967? 1967, 1967, September 3rd. It could maybe be. The left to right, that's the one we changed to right and perfect.
是的，我是瑞典人。好的。冷不丁地给瑞典人打电话的是威尔·科利。我是一名记者，我有一个问题想问你。当我告诉你1967年9月3日这个日期时，你会想到什么？1967年，1967年，9月3日。可能是吧。从左到右，那是我们改成右侧行驶的日子，非常完美。
We called about a dozen Swedes, and for the most part, if they are alive and in country for any part of the 1960s. The date September 3rd 1967 was a hugely important and heralded day. Doggenho. Doggenho. H.D. Yeah, H.D. Yeah. Short for Huga Trafik Om Langningen or something like that. I think. Sorry. No, I'll get traffic on the beginning again. Meaning the right-hand traffic diversion. H.D. was the day that 7.8 million Swedes switched the side of the road they drive on, from the left side to the right.
我们给大约十二位瑞典人打了电话，大多数人如果在那段时期生活在瑞典，都会觉得1967年9月3日是一个非常重要且广为人知的日子。H日。H日。H日。是的，H日。是的。它是“Högertrafikomläggningen”的缩写，或者类似的意思。我想。抱歉。不，我再重新说一遍交通转换。意思是右侧交通转换。H日就是780万瑞典人将驾驶侧从左侧改为右侧的那一天。
It would be the most massive overhaul in driving infrastructure that any country had ever seen. Historically, if you're riding a horse, generally you want to keep to the left so that you can use your right hand to greet passers-by, or, you know, whack them with a sword. But with the advent of the horse-drawn carriage, there were some conditions in which it made sense to stick to the right, and customs could vary by country. And as cars became more common, they followed the same laws that were established for horse-drawn traffic. Up until 1967, Sweden drove on the left side of the road.
这将是任何国家所见过的最庞大的交通基础设施改造。从历史上看，如果你骑马，通常你会靠左走，这样你就可以用右手向路人打招呼，或者，你知道，用剑攻击他们。但随着马车的出现，在某些情况下靠右行驶是有道理的，习俗也因国家而异。随着汽车变得越来越普遍，它们遵循了为马车交通制定的相同法律。直到1967年，瑞典一直靠道路左侧行驶。
Which, set it apart from its neighboring countries, Finland, Norway, and Denmark, all of which drove on the right. And this presented problems. The biggest problem was the accidents with Swedish drivers abroad. And the visitors in Sweden who also had difficulties with a change from right and driving to left and driving. And these accidents increased continuously.
这使它与邻国芬兰、挪威和丹麦不同，这些国家都靠右行驶。这带来了问题。最大的问题是瑞典司机在国外的事故，以及在瑞典的游客在从右侧驾驶切换到左侧驾驶时也遇到了困难。这些事故持续增加。
This is psychologist Anders England. When he says left hand driving, he means driving on the left hand side of the road. When Anders started working with the Swedish government in the 1960s, they were tired of seeing Swedes getting into car accidents abroad and having tourists and truck drivers from other countries getting into car accidents in Sweden. There was also some motor vehicles were adapted to right hand driving. Swedish car companies made vehicles that were meant to be driven on the right, so they could be exported more easily.
这是心理学家安德斯·英格兰。当他说左侧驾驶时，他指的是在道路左侧行驶。当安德斯在20世纪60年代开始与瑞典政府合作时，他们厌倦了看到瑞典人在国外发生车祸，以及来自其他国家的游客和卡车司机在瑞典发生车祸。还有一些机动车辆是为右侧驾驶而改装的。瑞典汽车公司制造的车辆是为了在右侧行驶而设计的，这样它们可以更容易地出口。
But these cars also found their way onto roads in Sweden. And that was a problem. Namely having your steering wheel on the outside edge of the road. Overtaking or passing as you say in your country, you don't see the incoming cars. It was a big mess. The Swedish government thought it could get a lot better if they just switched what side of the road they drove on if they could drive on the right, like most of Europe.
但这些车也出现在了瑞典的道路上。这是一个问题。即方向盘位于道路的外侧边缘。超车，或者像你们国家说的那样“passing”，你看不到迎面而来的车。这真是一团糟。瑞典政府认为，如果他们能像欧洲大多数国家一样靠右行驶，情况会好得多。
Legislative action to switch driving side had been attempted before, few times actually, but it always failed. And then, in the early 1960s, the Swedish government thought that this could be the time. They put it to a public vote, asking the Swedish populist to decide. The answer from the people was a resounding no. 83% of the people in Sweden voted for keeping left hand driving. So the government just went ahead and did it anyway.
立法改变驾驶侧的行动以前曾尝试过，实际上有几次，但总是失败。然后，在20世纪60年代初，瑞典政府认为这可能是时候了。他们将其付诸全民公投，要求瑞典民众做出决定。人民的回答是一个响亮的“不”。83%的瑞典人投票支持保持左侧驾驶。所以政府还是直接这么做了。
Sweden likes to be looked upon as a democratic country and despite that the government decided that we must change this. Anders England served as part of the team that would help make that change. I was secretary in the scientific working group. As secretary, Anders supervised three teams. One assessing what methods they should deploy for an educational campaign. One trying to forecast what problems they might encounter, and the third one for mass media.
瑞典喜欢被视为一个民主国家，尽管如此，政府还是决定我们必须做出改变。安德斯·英格兰作为帮助实现这一变革的团队成员之一。我是科学工作组的秘书。作为秘书，安德斯监督了三个小组。一个评估他们应该为教育运动采取什么方法。一个试图预测他们可能遇到的问题，第三个负责大众媒体。
One of Anders' jobs is helping to come up with informational materials for the switch, like a pamphlet that would explain what would be different, what to watch out for, and what rules to follow. And just take a second to think about what kind of a job this is. If you've ever been in a car driving on the opposite side of what you're used to, everything feels wrong. So you need to teach people to identify what is actually correct even though it feels wrong,
安德斯的工作之一是帮助制定转换的信息材料，比如一本小册子，解释会有什么不同，要注意什么，以及要遵守什么规则。花一秒钟想一想这是什么样的工作。如果你曾经在与你习惯的相反的一侧开车，一切都感觉不对劲。所以你需要教人们识别什么是真正正确的，即使它感觉不对，
and what's actually just wrong, wrong. The pamphlet Anders and his team worked on shows where your car goes when you make a right turn or a left turn, how to pass, what pedestrians should be aware of. How they said move. How they said drive. The two most important things that the pamphlet did was, one, to familiarize Sweden with a new traffic sign.
以及什么是真正错误的。安德斯和他的团队制作的小册子展示了当你右转或左转时你的车应该去哪里，如何超车，行人应该注意什么。他们怎么说移动。他们怎么说驾驶。小册子所做的两件最重要的事情是，第一，让瑞典熟悉一个新的交通标志。
The six formed sign with a leaning H in the middle. A hexagon sign with an H in it. H for hugger or right. These signs would be visible on the roads after the switch, and there were also little stickers with an H you could put on the inside of your windshield to remind yourself while you're driving. In fact, you might still spot an H sticker
中间有一个倾斜的H的六边形标志。一个带有H的六边形标志。H代表“Höger”或“右”。这些标志在转换后会在道路上可见，还有带有H的小贴纸，你可以贴在挡风玻璃内侧，以便在开车时提醒自己。事实上，你可能仍然能看到H贴纸
inside some of the older cars in Sweden. The second super important part of the public education campaign was the date of the switch. September 3rd, 1967. Dog and Ho, H. Day. The pamphlet was a good start in getting people ready for H. Day, but soon the government realized they needed to bring out the big guns. They wanted to unleash their nation's most effective weapon for penetrating
在瑞典的一些旧车里。公共教育运动的第二个超级重要的部分是转换的日期。1967年9月3日。H日。这本小册子是让人们为H日做好准备的一个良好开端，但很快政府意识到他们需要动用重型武器。他们想释放他们国家最有效的武器来渗透
people's hearts and minds. Pop music. Swings Television Station had put out a competition to come up with the best song to teach people about H.D. The winner, the tell stars, with Paul Digg-Dill-Hurg at Spenzen. I hold the deal heard, then Spenzen. I hold the deal heard, then I'm not smooth. Translation, keep to the right, Svensson. Svensson, being a stereotypically common Swedish last name, like Smith or Jones. There's also a bit of wordplay here. In Swedish, keeping to the right is shorthand for being faithful to your spouse. Going left means having an affair.
人们的心灵。流行音乐。瑞典电视台举办了一场比赛，选出最好的歌曲来教人们关于H日的事情。获胜者是“Tell Stars”，演唱了《Håll dig till höger, Svensson》。翻译过来就是：靠右行驶，斯文森。斯文森是一个典型的普通瑞典姓氏，就像史密斯或琼斯。这里还有一点双关语。在瑞典语中，靠右行驶是忠于配偶的代名词。靠左走意味着有外遇。
The government had spent four years getting the country ready. The official HD pamphlet had gone out to every sweet. Det är en färg. Det är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det här är en av det and it was big don't you? September had arrived. The evening of the second became the morning of the third. Everyone knew the drill. Each day was here. All non-essential traffic was banned from the roads from late night to early morning. Most cars were kept off the road. The only people in the roadways were construction crews,
政府花了四年时间让国家做好准备。官方的H日小册子已经发给了每一位瑞典人。而且规模很大，不是吗？九月到了。二号的晚上变成了三号的早晨。每个人都知道流程。H日到了。所有非必要的交通在深夜到清晨被禁止上路。大多数汽车被禁止上路。道路上唯一的人是施工人员，
taxi drivers who were given the OK from the government. And a hand-picked few, like this guy. It was great fun. There were very few cars out in Stockholm. And I had one of the very few got a permission to drive at night when it was forbidden. This is Bow Home Strong. Well, I'm Bow Home Strong. I'm a Swedish journalist.
获得了政府许可的出租车司机。还有少数被挑选出来的人，比如这个家伙。这很有趣。斯德哥尔摩街上的车很少。我是极少数获得许可在禁止时段开车的人之一。这是博·霍姆斯特伦。嗯，我是博·霍姆斯特伦。我是一名瑞典记者。
I've been working since 1960 in the television as a television reporter. In 1967 I was working on the switch to a right hand drive traffic and doing a lot of stories about it. Boah is actually a pretty famous broadcast journalist, kind of like a Swedish Tom Brokaw. At the time this was the big story. Oh yeah, we were on the air almost all night and they have to two transmitting from different points in Sweden. Where crews were out putting up the hexagonal H signs. The ones reminding you to drive on the right, plus they had to flip around and move pretty
我从1960年开始在电视台担任电视记者。1967年，我正在报道转向右侧交通的工作，并做了很多关于它的报道。博实际上是一位非常著名的广播记者，有点像瑞典的汤姆·布罗考。当时这是一个大新闻。哦，是的，我们几乎整晚都在直播，他们不得不从瑞典的不同地点进行转播。工作人员在外面安装六边形的H标志。那些提醒你靠右行驶的标志，此外他们还必须翻转并移动几乎
much every street sign in the country. When I saw the changing of signs, turning them the other way, and the changing of signs at bus stops. There's such a great feeling to be biking around, 10 years old old and there was no traffic. A few of the random suites that we reached on the phone were also there on each day. And then of course there have a song that was going repeatedly on the radio. I can't record it but try to rewrite when something was something. I hope that you heard that Sven's song.
全国所有的路标。当我看到标志的更换，把它们转向另一边，以及公交车站标志的更换时。作为一个10岁的孩子骑车到处转，没有交通，感觉真好。我们通过电话联系到的少数随机瑞典人也参加了H日。当然，还有一首在广播里反复播放的歌。我录不下来，但试着重写了一些东西。我希望你听到了那首斯文森之歌。
Roundabouts were reconfigured for people to go counterclockwise and set up clockwise. Freeway off ramps became on ramps. Temporary bus stops were set up in the middle of the street to accommodate buses that now had doors on the wrong side. At 4.50 a.m., a horn blared across Stockholm and a loudspeaker announced, Now is the time to change over. And then, under the direction of thousands of traffic cops dispatched around the country,
环岛被重新配置，让人们逆时针行驶而不是顺时针。高速公路出口变成了入口。临时公交车站被设置在街道中间，以适应现在门开在错误一侧的公交车。凌晨4点50分，斯德哥尔摩响起了一声喇叭，扩音器宣布：“现在是转换的时候了。”然后，在全国各地部署的数千名交通警察的指挥下，
all of the cars in Sweden made their way to the right. For the most part, the H.D. transition team had accounted for everything. But it was disorienting, and not everyone was a happy camper. Some people said they got lost. They were in their own city. They had been driving there for years. They were used to take one by street, for example, and there was still one way, but the other way. So they couldn't go where they wanted.
瑞典所有的汽车都驶向了右侧。在很大程度上，H日过渡团队已经考虑到了所有事情。但这让人感到困惑，并不是每个人都感到高兴。有些人说他们迷路了。他们在自己的城市里。他们已经在那里开了多年车了。他们习惯走某条单行道，例如，它仍然是单行道，但方向变了。所以他们无法去他们想去的地方。
I remember one old lady or middle-aged lady sitting in the passenger seat in one car, we stopped and she was mad, mad as hell, saying, we didn't want this, we voted against it, everybody was against going over, damn politicians, they didn't start a war, but they're gonna get thousands of people killed in the traffic instead. But here's the really amazing thing about H.D. and the shift as a whole. The total number of traffic related deaths on H.D. was zero. In fact, the total number of accidents went down for a while.
我记得一位老太太或中年妇女坐在车里的乘客座位上，我们停下来，她很生气，非常生气，说：“我们不想要这个，我们投票反对它，每个人都反对转换，该死的政客，他们没有发动战争，但他们却要让成千上万的人在交通中丧生。”但关于H日和整个转变，真正令人惊奇的是：H日当天的交通死亡总人数为零。事实上，事故总数在一段时间内还下降了。
There were a lot of people thinking that this should be catastrophe. There should be thousands of dead people in the traffic. It didn't. Likely because everyone was so freaked out about driving on what felt like the wrongs are the road that for a while, everyone drove really slowly and carefully. A year after Sweden switched sides of the road, Iceland also switched to driving on the right to be more like the rest of Europe, the United Kingdom and Ireland not understanding. In the 1970s, former British colonies, including Ghana and Nigeria, switched from left to right to be more like their neighbors in West Africa and the rest of the world.
很多人认为这会是一场灾难。交通中应该有成千上万的死者。但并没有。很可能是因为每个人都对在感觉像是错误的道路一侧行驶感到非常害怕，所以有一段时间，每个人都开得非常缓慢和小心。瑞典改变道路侧一年后，冰岛也改为靠右行驶，以更像欧洲其他国家，英国和爱尔兰则没有。在20世纪70年代，包括加纳和尼日利亚在内的前英国殖民地从左侧改为右侧，以更像他们在西非和世界其他地区的邻国。
Today, the vast majority of the world drives on the right, and in places that do drive on the left, like in the UK, movements occasionally spring up, trying to get the country to switch to the right. But there is one notable exception, where a country went left. Office of the Prime Minister of Farm War, how may I help you? Samoa. Oh, hi, this is Will Kohli calling from New York. Hello, Mr. Kohli. Samoa is an island republic in the South Pacific, not to be confused with American Samoa, which is just east of Samoa. In 2009, they did the opposite of Sweden and nearly every other country who made
今天，世界上绝大多数国家靠右行驶，而在像英国这样靠左行驶的地方，偶尔会出现一些运动，试图让国家转向右侧。但有一个值得注意的例外，一个国家转向了左侧。萨摩亚总理办公室，我能为您提供什么帮助？萨摩亚。哦，你好，我是来自纽约的威尔·科利。你好，科利先生。萨摩亚是南太平洋的一个岛国，不要与萨摩亚东部的美国萨摩亚混淆。2009年，他们做了与瑞典和几乎所有其他国家相反的事情，
the switch. They went from driving on the right to driving on the left. Will Coley called up the guy responsible for the change? Okay, hold on for a minute. I'll transfer the call. Okay, thank you so much. Okay, thank you so much. Yes, this is the actual whole music, the office of... Hello. Hi, Prime Minister. Yes.
他们进行了转换。他们从靠右行驶改为靠左行驶。威尔·科利给负责这次改变的人打了电话。好的，请稍等片刻。我帮你转接电话。好的，非常感谢。好的，非常感谢。是的，这是真正的等待音乐，办公室……喂。你好，总理。是的。
I want the Prime Minister of South Park, who left the South and the Middle East and going. For Prime Minister Malay Le Moi, switching to the left offered one major obvious benefit, aligning Samoa, more closely with the B.A.R.R.R. and the B.A.R.R. for the first time. For Prime Minister Malay Le Moy, switching to the left offered one major obvious benefit, aligning Samoa more closely with the biggest nearby economies, Australia, New Zealand, and Japan. All of which drive on the left.
我想找萨摩亚总理……对于总理马莱莱莫伊来说，转向左侧提供了一个主要且明显的优势，即让萨摩亚与最大的邻近经济体——澳大利亚、新西兰和日本——更加紧密地保持一致。所有这些国家都靠左行驶。
Well, it's saying something that we have been thinking about for a long time, mainly because we needed to import cheaper cars. Samoa wanted to import cheap used cars from nearby Japan. Japan has the cheapest to sit and earn car market in the world. But cars in Japan are made to be driven on the left, so Samoa decided to make the switch to left side driving. It's a real common sense. By all accounts the day of the switch, September 7th 2009 was really smooth.
嗯，这说明我们已经考虑了很长时间，主要是因为我们需要进口更便宜的汽车。萨摩亚想从附近的日本进口廉价二手车。日本拥有世界上最便宜的汽车市场。但日本的汽车是为靠左行驶而制造的，所以萨摩亚决定转向左侧驾驶。这真的是常识。据所有报道，转换当天，2009年9月7日，非常顺利。
It probably helped that there were only a couple of major roads to modify. It began with a radio announcement from Prime Minister Malay Lemawi. The great event that would be most helpful to our livelihood and that is to die on the right-hand side of the road. And the switch was that this was perfect. That was great, but you said right hand. I think you meant left hand, right? Yeah, yeah, sorry, sorry. Yeah.
这可能有所帮助，因为只有几条主要道路需要修改。它始于总理马莱莱莫伊的广播公告。这对我们的生计最有帮助的伟大事件，那就是在道路的右侧行驶。转换是完美的。那很好，但你说了右侧。我想你是指左侧，对吧？是的，是的，抱歉，抱歉。是的。
Stick to the rights, Fenson. Prime Minister Malay Lamawi, stick to the left. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Will Coley and Sam Greenspan, with Katie Mingle, Sheree Fuzef, Delaney Hall, Kurt Colesdead, Avery Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Peter Kincaid, author of Rules of the Road, also thanks to Diana Kincaid, Yuwan Nicholson, Gustav Algren, Ambassador Fitturi Alessaya, Boris Linkwist, Kate Montague, Rowena Fatouava-Vavatal, and the Swedish Radio Archives.
靠右行驶，斯文森。总理马莱莱莫伊，靠左行驶。《99%隐形》本周由威尔·科利和萨姆·格林斯潘制作，凯蒂·明格尔、谢丽·福泽夫、德莱尼·霍尔、库尔特·科尔斯蒂德、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。特别感谢《道路规则》的作者彼得·金凯德，也感谢戴安娜·金凯德、尤万·尼科尔森、古斯塔夫·阿尔格伦、大使菲图里·阿莱萨亚、鲍里斯·林奎斯特、凯特·蒙塔古、罗威娜·法图阿瓦-瓦瓦塔尔和瑞典广播档案馆。
And thanks to our random suites, Kenneth Johnson, Lucas Nielsen, Hans Bjorkmann, Mona Nortazavi, and Yulah Grunas. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produce the offices of Arksign, an architecture and interiors firm. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. Follow us all on Twitter and Instagram, but the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world is to click around the hundreds of stories, now both audio stories and print stories on 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢我们的随机瑞典人：肯尼斯·约翰逊、卢卡斯·尼尔森、汉斯·比约克曼、莫娜·诺塔扎维和尤拉·格鲁纳斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的Arksign建筑和室内设计公司办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。在Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，但探索塑造我们世界设计的《99%隐形》活动的最好方式是点击99pi.org上数百个故事，现在既有音频故事也有文字故事。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。